détenue par la gauche depuis 1998 le
canton de saint cyr l'école pourrait
peut-être basculé à droite dimanche
prochain le duo union de la droite
philippe benassaya et sonia bros arrive
en tête du premier tour avec 39,18 % des
voix content de la mobilisation parce
que bien supérieur à ce qui avait été
annoncé et puis content du résultat je
pense qu'une campagne de terrain qui a
porté ses fruits il faut continuer à
mobiliser
les électeurs parce que rien n'est joué
mais ce résultat est un bel espoir il
reste une semaine et on va continuer à
se mobiliser sur la semaine qui
réunirent philippe benassaya réalise le
grand chelem à bois d'arcy commune dont
il est le maire en remportant tous les
bureaux avec et 41 98% des voix pour
autant ils le savent rien n'est joué
face à eux pour le second tour fabienne
gelgon bilbo et jean philippe mallet
conseiller général sortant socialiste
ils ont réuni 24,40 % des suffrages lors
du premier tour pour nous c'est quand
même un motif on va dire de satisfaction
que je rappelle simplement que depuis
trois semaines tous les français ont pu
voir que tous les sondages mettez le
parti socialiste a très loin derrière en
troisième position à 19 20 % dont on
sent bien bien au delà ce canton n'est
pas passé à droite il ya il y aura un
deuxième tour on va faire une campagne
pour ce deuxième tour les trois autres
binômes ont été écarté du second tour en
3e position julien grimm et perrine
géniaux pour le fn ont remporté 19
points 89 % des suffrages des résultats
qu'il qualifie d' encourageants vient
ensuite le binôme front de gauche europe
ecologie les verts avec 12 points 0 3%
et enfin debout la france avec 4,50 pour
cent des voix nous prônons je dirais la
responsabilité citoyenne
nous faisons confiance à nos électeurs
pour prendre
la bonne décision et ne donnons pas de
consigne de vote ta parti républicain
nous avons entre des électeurs qui
viennent de droite comme de gauche des
électeurs qui viennent à nous
directement et qui ont des convictions
quand une réflexion au premier tour
s'ils sont capables de réagir au premier
tour sur maps ou encore lord stress qui
vont faire au second debout la france et
du rassemblement front de gauche europe
ecologie les verts restent toutefois
fixer sur un même objectif continuer
leur combat respectif et défendre leurs
positions au delà des échéances
électorales
46% des électeurs se sont déplacés aux
urnes dimanche pour les deux binômes
encore en lice il reste une semaine pour
mobiliser les abstentionnistes